well we all know despite its gorgeous
weather and abundant resources
California is bleeding residents more
than a half million leaving between
April 2020 and July 2022 alone
now as shocking as it may seem high
taxes high crime and reparations
payments aren't huge draws
in fact the Democrat super majority in
the state legislature is so desperate to
keep people from leaving the state that
they're threatening them with an exit
tax if they do
now shockingly left-wing Governor Gavin
Newsom opposes this cash grab but we
figured out why because Governor hair
gel has bigger aspirations
we know we have a big battle coming
which is why we'll help lead the fight
to make sure we elect leaders in 2024
who believe in democracy our country is
facing an existential battle for who we
are and who we're willing to become
it's not an exaggeration
the truth what's happening in those red
States
it's not who we are it's Un-American
it's undemocratic
right gav and your closing of churches
and schools and various businesses for
more than a year it was just what our
Founders would have done it was so
pluralistic of you chasing those people
off the beaches
well his big national tour announcement
late last month made no reference to
fixing the economy or the Border or
standing up to China nope because he has
no answers there
so it's all about stoking hate and
division by revving up the culture wars
we're going on the road to take the
fight to states where freedom is most
under attack where Republican leaders
ban books criminalize doctors fired
teachers intimidate Librarians kidnap
migrants Target trans kids Stow gracism
now an obvious dry run for a different
campaign theme well Newsome's red state
tour is just the latest sign that
President Biden May either not run at
all or he may have serious competition
now check out Biden's numbers in the
newest CNN poll even CNN couldn't spin
them
just a third of the Americans polled in
this survey 32 percent of the exact say
yes 67 percent nearly two-thirds of
Americans does not believe that he
deserves re-election there was a bit of
an up an upward trajectory after the
November midterms that little uptick has
seemed to stalled out
now at stalled out and his
campaign-style tour Newsome generally
avoided hitting the areas where Biden is
literally and figuratively stumbling
he performs worse on individual issues
than his overall approval rating only 45
percent say he's honest and trustworthy
only 35 percent say he inspires
confidence 32 percent says he has the
stamina and sharpness for the job these
are absolutely disastrous numbers which
is why Newsome basically shadowed
Biden's trip to Selma last month by
going to Montgomery where the Bloody
Sunday March ended because when we think
of Gavin Newsom the son of privilege and
the founder of plump Jack Winery we
think moral crusader
I'm here in Montgomery Alabama as a
reminder not only the moral courage of
leaders like Dr King and Rosa Parks but
all the hard work that was done after
those moments on which the rollback of
the progress that we've all enjoyed that
we have a lot of work to do to build a
movement to counter what's happening in
red States across this country
what's this thing he keeps doing that's
very strange but he's hoping for a
Newsome movement to knock off president
stumbles and he's trying to demonize the
red States and to do it of course he's
not going to run on you know lowering
your gas prices instead if he runs he'll
take the unimaginative path of running
against Trump
the problem in our country right now
authoritarian leaders who are so
hell-bent on gaining power and keeping
it by whatever means necessary that
they're directly attacking our freedoms
in state after State that's why I'm
launching the campaign for democracy
lame
we had more people vote in the last
election than ever before and record
turnout in the midterms as well so this
is a totally weak argument about
democracy in fact if anyone's
threatening democracy it's the people
who want to pack the Supreme Court
but his argument is not as weak as the
performances in Florida
[Music]
[Applause]
it's totally offbeat
is it just me or is he unable to clap on
Beat
by the way if he's a Democrat nominee
how does he take on the man who won
re-election by 20 points well Newsome
spoke to students at Florida's new
College where DeSantis has begun to
restore the proper balance to public
higher education
his message was that DeSantis launched a
war on the college and was hurting
students threatening their education he
told them I want you to know you're not
alone you matter we care
oh inspiring
now sure this is a lot of hot air and I
don't think he's going to get very far
in Florida with that message it's
booming economy and pro-business
environment is a magnet for Americans
why would voters in Florida or anywhere
else for that matter want to take advice
from the same people who are destroying
California
now let's be candid almost no place on
Earth has the advantages of Gavin
newsom's California in terms of beauty
climate natural resources
there's a reason it's long been known as
the Golden State
if Gavin newsom's policies don't lead to
a healthy economy in California and they
don't
how could they possibly work anywhere
else
but Republicans should do more than
laugh Newsom off
they shouldn't run away from a debate
with him instead they should embrace it
Republicans have to remember that the
Reagan Library is not the only
institution in California there are
almost 40 million of our fellow
Americans living there including over 6
million people who voted for President
Trump in 2020. we can't abandon them
every Republican seeking national office
should make a point of going to
California and making clear to them that
we want to help
joining me now Harmony Dillon CEO of the
center for American Liberty and attorney
extraordinaire
um Harmony Gavin Newsom on his tour I
mean it is pretty hilarious uh he's
presided over the utter decline of
California he's ushering in more Decline
and yet he thinks he has the answer for
what ails America your thoughts
well Laura I think if I'm a presidential
candidate on the Republican side running
against Gavin Newsom what I would be
focusing on on a daily basis is showing
b-roll from California cities and from
the Central Valley and showing how
making California into a sanctuary state
for every ill in this country drug abuse
illegal immigration transgender
mutilation of children has really
destroyed the quality of life in our
city I mean this is a city where a
millionaire was murdered on the streets
just a couple of days ago and where cops
are retiring early because the
prosecutors don't prosecute crimes and
so he should be running from California
he I I don't hear him talking about
California a lot on his tour around the
country because it isn't a pretty story
getting people to the polls in
California is not going to be done with
the transgender message it's not going
to be done on the Dobbs case it's just
not it's going to be done on on giving
people their dreams back and giving
America a chance against China a real
fighting chance against China maybe the
Border a little bit but it's the economy
stupid I keep saying this and I keep
hearing people get you know pulled off
for the last latest shiny object
you're absolutely right Laura and the
vicissitudes of the economy are such
that last year you could sell your house
in California and probably make a profit
on it if you'd had it for a little bit
of time right now the housing prices are
in a tailspin so people who have
mortgages are locked into them and we
don't have a lot of Mobility at the same
time
companies are laying people off right
and left and you know jobs are shrinking
so I think we're really heading for a
cliff here in California and other blue
States and we have yet to see the worst
of it and I don't know how Gavin Newsom
is going to deal with that I think he's
frankly checked out of California at
this point
um how would you rate how the RNC is
preparing for 2024 so far in state maybe
state gops with the mail invalid ballot
harvesting problem we're going to see
again in places like Wisconsin and other
states
one to ten
what we just saw in Wisconsin shows it's
maybe a two right now and so I think
that we haven't gotten the message yet
that we need to be investing uh my
people on the ground are telling me
Democrats had about 500 ballot Chasers
in Wisconsin we had a tiny fraction of
that maybe less than 10 percent of that
so it's not serious we really need to
really change our attitude
that's that's that's the key you got to
win elections right Harmony thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else